hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and I am checking in on you um
you know I do this show I usually you
know how I do I usually talk here to
myself I usually babble
I usually ramble and then I try to read
out loud but every once in a while I
have a special guest and this is one of
these Thursdays this man is here to
promote his new book everybody is awful
except for you that will be you can
pre-order now and it's gonna be
available on Amazon Barnes and Nobles
and all that stuff please welcome jim
Florentine everybody it's good to see
you bill I have me back man you like I
did the big build-up I said the book I
did the whole thing I was waiting for
everybody to sit back and try and guess
who the hell it was gonna be you know
and then then I then I dropped the name
on it that's old-school showbiz right
there that is cuz then like who could it
be maybe it's you know someone hasn't
talked a while maybe he's getting a
louis c.k exclusive maybe louise going
back there maybe he's coming back and
he's gonna do it on bills podcast and
you know we were just talking about that
you might as well dive in that homie to
thing it's just like obviously had to
happen everything but it is such like a
bully environment even like the [ __ ]
want if it's a [ __ ] one you can't
say anything like recently one came out
it was just like all right this just
seemed like this woman wanted a famous
boyfriend and it didn't happen and then
the end she went on her friends blog or
some [ __ ] and trashed this guy and I
can't even name names before all these
[ __ ] lunatics start coming out like
there's no there's no like hey hey hey
let's let's let's examine this it's just
all this person said that that means
that's how it happened that's how the
whole thing went down and let's burn
down this person's life and their entire
bility to earn a living is a little nuts
absolutely and be me being a single guy
out there absolutely you don't know
what's do you like sign in triplicate
before you be like I'm trying to get
like you know Shaq's contract they used
to sign or Michael Jordan or whatever it
supposedly had a thing where they would
sign like there are Cisco okay you go in
the hotel room next door you know what's
gonna happen
sign here
yes this out this is so here's a consent
you could sent to order and then you
know what you're going in there and you
guys gonna have sex and that's it
what about funny one of the funnier
things that I've read as far as like
just all this extreme mindset that's out
there about politics that's out there
about about this me to set everything is
just you have to be like all the way on
the other side of room against the wall
or all the way on the other one is um oh
god dude I'm getting so old I literally
forgot my point right in the middle of
it I swear to god I was gonna make the
greatest point I literally just [ __ ]
for what the [ __ ] wasn't oh I know
there's gonna be a lot of this by the
way coercion is not consent is what they
said when you coerced someone into doing
something that is not consent so that
was thinking like okay does that mean I
don't have to pay my bank loan this
[ __ ] month on my on my car loan hey
buddy you don't want this man you want
the turbo man you come around the corner
they here in that engine the the whole
[ __ ] world is coercion everybody our
whole business everything you anytime
you sell anything any of it have to [ __ ]
my wife does to me dude if coercion is
not consent and women actually stuck by
that would brunch still exist and that's
a good point
no no guy if you actually could see want
to go to that no I do not and then she
that's coercion like because you're
meeting you're like I'll [ __ ] I want
to cry anytime a guy goes to brunch he's
taking the bullet on something oh my
word the worst is when they come out
they said it's gonna be like 40 minutes
is that gonna be can you stand like you
have the option to say no I mean I say
no that's why I fight with my wife so
much no let's get out of here yeah we
could I can I can literally Google how
to make [ __ ] no pun intended eggs
florentine go to supermarkets eggs and
steam [ __ ] spinach on an English
muffin I can figure this out no but I
just has a fun ambiance here so look
obviously it's great to dis a forum now
that all these these some of the [ __ ]
this guys did know who the [ __ ] knew
people did that I mean I knew there was
[ __ ] creeps out there but like now
it's just getting it's getting to the
point but with not it's not getting to
the point but there's been a few
where there's a few things where it's
like you couldn't handle that amongst
yourselves like that I need to know all
the gory details of what you guys did
here and then there's other ones that
are just complete [ __ ] but I still
don't feel that we're at a place where
you can actually say that because I
think if you do then then what then
you're a rapist yeah then yeah
absolutely you condone it and you
understand women now they just said we
just want the guys to listen we don't
want them to respond
don't come back like you're in a
relationship and when your girls
complaining about something the law I
know how to fix it but just listen that
makes sense if what they're saying is
true yeah
exactly no if you but if you're telling
a [ __ ] if you're talking about apples
and you say in their oranges and then
you're telling me I'm supposed to shut
the [ __ ] up and then watch somebody I
know lose their [ __ ] life their
career that doesn't make sense either
and I feel like a lot of people feel
that and everyone's choosing like
self-preservation like so I keep hitting
the table here like like the Golden
Globes right when you went to that it's
like dude if you didn't have a black
shirt underneath your tuxedo I mean you
you you were finished that meant you
advocated sexual assault that night then
you had a word to pin all the times up
thing but here's the thing you literally
could have just sexually assaulted
somebody but wore a black shirt and had
the pin and no one would [ __ ] with you
right so I don't eat I don't I'm old I
sew I don't I don't get what's going on
anymore I don't get it sorry man you're
here to sell a book no no no I'm gonna
get into no I do want to get into it no
absolutely I mean it is the story that
we're talking about it's just insane you
know it was there was oral sex performed
full-time two times on here on each
other
and then when he wanted to have
intercourse he's like now I don't know
when he's like alright you know well
hang or whatever like that and then he
had a funny line no I thought it was a
funny joke so he goes come on let's just
have intercourse who's everybody
and she goes you know what I'd rather
wait for the second date for that and he
was at his place and he goes so if I
pour you a new glass of wine is that
considered a second date that's a
[ __ ] funny line the guy's throwing
out there it's a desperate love
it is funny and then she is now and then
and then they hung out for a little
longer and she cuz I'm just gonna go
home she wasn't upset he goes okay I'll
get your car serviced sent her in a car
text her next day I had a good time he
last night well I didn't and then that's
how it started some of these these what
do you call the Cougars after a show
like if you were if you go out and
you're selling anything dude you're
gonna get manhandled when you're out
there come and handle [ __ ] once a
weekend it happens to me because I sell
merchandise after a show once a weekend
yeah yeah grab my ass literally
something if you did it like over put
put your hand on my wife's tit no it's
okay or a girl goes hey put it on my
tits come on it'll be funny or every
time all the time you gotta come out
after a show now you know those guys
wear that suit well you [ __ ] you
dismantle a bomb well tell me what is
the book about because I already like I
love the title it's everybody everybody
is awful and then parentheses except you
did like how I heard that was everybody
you know on Facebook going on and on
about how great they are and like how
the world's so awful and you know I
don't just having the whole you know
selfie the selfie generation yeah that's
basically what it is it just call them
people out bad Facebook posts you know
people brag and people looking for
attention you know you know the person
that posts oh and I'm on my way to the
hospital and they just leave it at that
I go okay so now you're gonna get fifty
what's wrong yeah well are you okay if I
lived in New Jersey I'd be there for you
but I can you please keep us updated
is everything okay and then at the end
it was just a sore throat oh yeah you
know what I mean it's never you always
figure you always figure out these these
these things like this Crank Yankers all
the way to this you always fun
terrorizing telemarketers you always
find like that that thing that that
people are like and I know it's I always
say whenever you do a project I wished
it was right [ __ ] there I was hanging
right there you just do up like this
you've done the the what was supposed to
show on vh1 I just went black metal [ __ ]
that metal show yeah yeah you how did
you know that there was gonna be a not
like there was a bunch of people like me
who wanted to know what Bobby Blosser
was doing I was so excited to see all
those guys like there was such a huge
part of my life and you know
part of my life you know is you're a
teenager he's a drama for rat by the way
you know as a paint just being a
teenager where there's sort of all of
this exciting stuff and then all of this
scary and depressing [ __ ] all happening
at the same time and that music was so
great and so fun that like I mean all of
those guys in those those bands to me
aren't the same level of like the fonts
well like when I was a really little kid
like the Fonz I had the Trading Cards
and literally you looking at somebody
like made my childhood happier when I
watch to show that metal show I was like
oh my god I [ __ ] love that guy like
what what is is it just how your brain
works like how do you always seem to
find I don't know I think we just got it
a good time BH one classic was like
looking for one original program they
didn't have anything on it just show him
repeats of just rolled music videos and
we pitched like a heavy-metal talk show
like The Tonight Show for ac/dc fans
they said okay we'll give you money for
one pilot we'd pulled Lita Ford out of
retirement she didn't do anything like
20 years she was living on an island
raising her kids so we had her as a
pilot episode with like I doesn't know
what he's back on the road she never
sees her kids yeah great mom he's been a
great mom till we gave her exposure to
hell damn I got a career next I know she
put three albums out in the last nine
years and then you know and luckily the
head of like vh1 classic this guy used
to be a deed of like a metal DJ up in
Buffalo he goes I love this show put it
on the air you know he's gonna be a
shitty but budget and I remember my
manager goes this is the worst contract
I've ever seen in my life you sure you
want to sign us ago yeah look whatever
who cares well at least we'll be on the
air and we did 140 episodes what seven
seasons who is uh some of your favorites
that because I knew that you you were
kind of already in that world a little
bit like a lot of you guys like you
Norton and all those got big J you guys
seem to like know Brewer bro er yeah
guys seem to know like rockstars and
stuff like that you were kind of already
in that world but when you went there
what was like your bucket list of guests
and were you able to get most of them
yeah I mean with Tony Iommi you know we
got geezer butler Ronnie James Dio
before he passed away right was on twice
then we got Marilyn Manson you know we
got Tom Morello from Rage Against the
Machine I'm a huge fan we got Steve
Harris from Iron Maiden so every every
season was somebody different like you
got to be
ketta Sammy Hagar Michael Anthony you
know I loved about Steve Harris was even
people who had not knew nothing about
music would be like that guy is an
unbelievable bass player yeah he was
yeah his fingers just flying actually
Iron Maiden was the one that when I
first wanted to play drums it was a
drama
Nicko McBrain that was one of those one
of those scream from a long beach you
know that they filmed or whatever and I
just remember when they finally went
behind him because you should always see
the arms moving yeah you could never see
him he's buried in her so when I saw the
legs moving to I was like that looks
[ __ ] cool and I already failed on
guitar because he actually had to like
no notes and [ __ ] yeah and it's coming
from more of a sports background because
that guy you just kind of beat the [ __ ]
out of this I know after after it looks
like fun
after a you know big Patriot loss you
can Obama pounding the drums I know
speaking of which at what do you I know
you're a and there's a famous story
about you you're a huge Miami Dolphins
fan there's this story that Keith
Robinson has told me probably a dozen
times and I never stopped them because I
loved it was you Iran you are in some
flight watching a dolphin game and you
will you were going please tell me it's
true right you were landing and the
stewardess told you to shut that your
phone off or whatever you were watching
you you refused to because yeah it was
an important part it's like this is
before cellphones I had one of those
little TVs with the antenna you know
it's a little bot and it was a play it
was a dolphin suit I'd also Bobby Kelly
can you find the next thing he always
said that [ __ ] this was like an I don't
know probably 99 who was that well I
were of 98 when Montana was on the
Chiefs it was a golfing chief playoff
game and I was on a flight from Florida
and it was on like the local ABC there's
a playoff game so I had one of those
little old-school TVs with an antenna
and I watched under a blanket the whole
game because I don't have to switch like
a moment we're in South Carolina I got
to find the ABC affiliate there and then
when I'm on yeah and I'm switching
around like this and I'm in Baltimore I
got to find the other judge so I watched
a whole game and a woman came over like
20 minutes left you have a TV on shut
that off it's gonna affect the plane I
go too bad I go it's it's I go it's 21
21 and Marino's driving with two minutes
left because you got a shot gone I'm not
shutting it off I don't care and even
when the plane landed I still
the whole thing and they won like right
as the plane landed I'm like yes oh
that's why I was pre 9/11 it was pre
9/11 and I had that little yeah and you
couldn't have any any kind of electronic
device on the plane I know but I'm
saying if now if you said no oh yeah
that would have been like you know like
the CIA
absolutely yeah they wouldn't wait would
come on and [ __ ] ya know been waiting
for me when I landed but yeah I would
not shut the TV off on the note I wanted
on the black I didn't get caught - like
20 minutes left in the flight I watched
the whole game my girlfriend at the time
was sitting next to me I was screaming
she was miserable there's a way to end a
bad trip on my head too bad breaking up
again anyway when I got back I didn't
know JetBlue cuz I was thinking well why
wouldn't they just shut the thing on
your own team I am my own little TV I
brought it just in case ago Nick I was
already doing the math I'm like if they
win they're gonna play on Saturday at
4:30 might that's what my flight is so
I'm bringing my TV just a case and
that's exactly what happened Wow do you
know what when the Patriots beat Seattle
I was flying from Sydney Australia to
like Auckland New Zealand and I missed
the whole game because I was thinking
that it's a Super Bowl they show it
around the world they're gonna have it
on like you know they had TVs all they
had was soccer I was like you got to be
kidding me so when I got off the plane I
knew it was towards the end of the game
but I just had to know so I told I asked
my wife I go I go what's the score and
she's like um says the Patriots are
winning and I was like really no cuz I
was still you know after those two giant
losses I was like oh god now he's gonna
be three and three you know [ __ ] and I
go how much time's left and she's like
um it says it's over I go no way [ __ ] it
started scream in the middle of New
Zealand look like a maniac and then I
went back to the hotel and they were
just showing the Superbowl in this weird
channel with no commercials and I
watched it twice back-to-back and then I
watched it again the next morning and I
couldn't like I had no idea about that
hopefully in the end or anything like
that but uh anyways getting back to the
initial thing I was gonna ask you a lot
of people you know are talking about the
Jaguars and their defense you know and
they're going into New England
you know nobody thought that they were
going to go
to Pittsburgh well some people did but
they went in there they won there they
beat Buffalo Bills but they beat the
bills and it was like this snooze fest
and then you know they went into the
Steelers and they had like a shootout
so everybody's talking about how great
their defense is and I'm silly they just
gave up like 40 41 points but the week
before who the [ __ ] are they so jim
Florentine a man who brought a TV on a
[ __ ] plane in 1999 what is your gut
feeling Patriots Patriots absolutely
you don't win in Foxborough and you know
in Patriots to Gillette Stadium you
don't win their a championship game you
think Bella checks this feels were
looking past the Jaguars waiting for the
championship game they always [ __ ]
dudes always do it that would they came
out here we played them they'd already
they already bought their [ __ ] plane
like that's the you know the urban myth
they've I'd already bought their plane
tickets and hotel reservations down in
New Orleans yeah we got Belichick to
prepare for Blake bortles they got no
shot yeah I don't care what kind of
defense back that running back got hurt
too yeah but that defense looks good but
to do but that's alright birdie we'll
pick him up our finest um but last week
they did know some guy will come off the
practice squad tomorrow and he'll catch
ten passes on Sunday how long can we do
this we just keep doing it and do we he
doesn't have a number one this isn't we
don't have a number one receiver right
now with Edelman being out the whole
year and you know I know we got Gronk
he's a tight in but like you know it's
just there's a lot of pastors day I
don't know know there's a one guy he
[ __ ] stops it's like keep running
keep a lot of time to see Brady go and
like just keep [ __ ] running so I
don't know like this this game scares me
this game scares me because they can do
the whole thing Jax until today he's
supposed to be here they got nothing to
lose but ba-ba-ba-ba-bom getting all
nervous about that
no I think that but they had their run I
mean they bet if the Bills had any kind
of quarterback they should have bought
one that game the first playoff game and
Pittsburgh was waiting from New England
they overlooked that they weren't
prepared you saw the first quarter they
weren't even but you know the head was
in a different game Patriots get the
only problem they could have is maybe if
they play Minnesota in Minnesota because
the game will be a home game
I was nervous about it's like the Saints
like I called that Saints game I called
a nose like Drew Brees is gonna go in
there he gets no respect
he's like the third all-time passer and
all that [ __ ] he's gonna go in there I
kept saying that you know all these
Minnesota fans we're gonna go to the
Mall of America going to the giant
Kleenex store and they were gonna be
crying and everything and exactly what
the [ __ ] I said was gonna happen until
that last play with 14 seconds left
which I have never ever in the history
of watching people [ __ ] up I have never
seen anybody do what that poor kid did
it's like he put his head down and
stopped looking at the guy and then he
throw he basically threw a block took
out his own [ __ ] guy just I've never
I still cannot [ __ ] believe that that
happened we I was watching a game a
bunch of friends of ours at 17 nothin
halftime my brother Gamble's he's like
all right look there's 10 to 1 odds you
want to put on the Saints come back and
win this game so we put like two
thousand dollars in a pot so I would
have won 800 bucks if they would have
just made it right there and it was 5
right the spread was 5 but we had to
just sort of Saints to win the game from
the second half they were down 79th and
a half time I go I'll do that so they
had the win the half a win the game win
the whole game at 17 nothing I'm like
I'll put 8 80 bucks and I would have won
800 bucks and I'm watching that we're
all you guys doing we're old money we're
like yes all right good we got this or
you owe this all right now I'm only down
this and this and then we'll watch the
last play like pictured all you guys
walking and talking to dinero with
buying your wives furs and stuff what I
said what I say don't buy anything don't
take it back and you oh my god that's
[ __ ] do you I wish you guys had the
reaction video or that you guys just
talking about all this [ __ ] you I was
already crashing with my bats oh my god
cool I'm only down 34 today I'm there so
you took this and we're just already
figuring out like we got this that's one
of those games I immediately went to
YouTube to see people's reactions to it
and these [ __ ] nerds were like the
first people that put theirs up and it
was the worst reaction ever they're like
oh my god wow that's crazy
they already monetized it and everything
I'm right [ __ ] mad at him I wanted to
see Saints fans
crying and Viking fans crying because I
figured like the best reaction video I
ever saw was when when Auburn my
favorite warning when a burn caught that
that field goal that came up short
against Alabama and the dude ran the
whole thing back like Alabama was
kicking to to win the game and it was a
long field goal and if they missed who
gives a [ __ ] we go into overtime I
believe that was the scenario and it
came up short you can return it the
Auburn guy [ __ ] caught it and they
caught him sleeping and he ran it like a
hundred five yards back and my favorite
one was these two girls one was for
Auburn one was for Alabama and the one
screaming cow go the other ones like
freaking out and then the end the
[ __ ] Auburn girl looks to the Alabama
girl who's just totally stunned she's
like y'all just lost so anyways I keep
forgetting to talk about the book so you
can pre-order this thing wait where do
they go they go to iTunes they go to
iBook where you go Amazon it's all the
links up on Amazon
oh the link is up on Amazon it's jim
Florentine everybody is awful except you
it comes out February 20 just me it's
basically based off my podcast where I
just you know people send in like bad
facebook posts or like vanity plates you
know awful vanity this is some of this
stuff bed of Hennessy [ __ ] power wash
off of Facebook rule number 10 drown us
in dumbass details oh this is [ __ ]
great and ID's are actual Facebook post
by people are posted and then I just you
know just take them take them down you
know like the weather post in Ohio you
know a mother nature you know go away he
was funny is earlier this year I went to
this [ __ ] award show and one of these
ones that was not televised that's the
level that I'm at in this business right
so I had a friend of mine he's got a man
this is gonna be like this big [ __ ]
thing blah blah blah blah blah you know
eventually maybe it'll be a big award
show you know if you want to go my wife
loves music and a double date law bless
it alright let's go
so right before we're gonna go the other
couple has to cancer because of some
[ __ ] so now we're going to this
[ __ ] thing that I you know my God
Jesus Christ so we show up dude I swear
to God every [ __ ] person say it's a
people won awards that night 19 people
cried and talked about how hard it was
and everything they went through and
blah blah blah blah blah and I was just
sitting there I just wanted to yell out
you're in your twenties how hard could
you ten years ago you were in high
school you're accepting a [ __ ] award
and you got a hit album how [ __ ] hard
could how I could have been I was like
almost 20 years in still on a [ __ ]
futon right nothing I don't know
I was I was paying my bills would change
at thirty six years old
hey Jesus taking it down there to change
thing at the supermarket you know like
they take like eight cents off a dollar
that was paying at 36 yeah here's the
thing like who gives a [ __ ]
like like I don't know I like I don't
know the entertainment business is
difficult like is it easy for somebody
else nobody goes into this business even
if you make it in two seconds then all
that means is you're gonna get [ __ ]
slammed back down to the ground because
when you start to dip you're not gonna
know how to handle it and you're gonna
[ __ ] and freak out it's better to get
punched in the face repeatedly as you're
walking up the hill other than to just
be on the chairlift go right up to the
top and the first time you'll drop a ski
or something like that although you're
just gonna go right down the other side
of the mountain so I actually it was one
of the few times where I was semi
ruining something did your wife know you
were annoyed yeah but she thought it was
funny she did she didn't think it was
funny because it right from right in the
beginning it was annoying I got there
and this guy like I'm standing there you
know the panic you know when you get
like you're unlike the guest list and
you know they're gonna forget your name
and it's like I don't see and then they
found it I had like this relief and all
of a sudden the security guys just like
excuse me sir
sir I'm gonna need you to clear this we
need to clear that and I'm thinking like
I'm in this totally open area this woman
had to [ __ ] walk by it was just some
I don't know I don't know who the [ __ ]
it was but like she literally had ten
feet on either side of us and the guy
was still telling me I needed to get
further up it's like do you want me to
become part of the paint I don't know so
sorry this is just podcast is becoming
about me complaining no no no that's
perfect that's what it should be why I
don't know everyone said I want to have
a guest and I try to want to like
lighten it up for something how is the
want to lighten it up okay how's the New
York comedy scene it's great it's been
have you been uh you know I moved away
believe it or not like over ten years
ago so when I go back now I don't know
who a lot of the new people are all all
of the there's a ton of them yeah this
should be not and a good you know the
good it's thriving man there's all the
clubs they're packed and III really like
to stand the stand is my club an assist
and it's great love that place
and there's there's Dangerfield's I
still love I haven't walked in there in
15 years and then the New York Comedy
Club al doesn't own it anymore no it's
gotten better
all right it's actually a decent gauge
and then they got the village on the
ground it's like the Comedy Cellar and
they got like three or three but they
did eight when I was in New York the
seller had the seller they had the wah I
don't think they had the village is it
village underground I think they had
that no yeah I'd like yeah they're like
like playing Monopoly like they keep
they got the free room you like ten
shows on a Saturday night it's
incredible I'm about used to be so
jealous of when I was living with Bobby
Kelly we would both have nine shows but
I would be all over the city and he
would he would have three at the Boston
three at the WA three at the cellar and
he didn't have to take one cab he could
just walk to all of them and he you know
you got paid fifty bucks this yeah so we
have nine 50s and I'd have a bunch of
20s and fives I'll smash together from
jumping in cabs going from the strip
down to the cellar back up to stand up
New York can you do that anymore I know
they kind of switched the way they some
of those guys yeah you could still do
what it's I try to stay like that one
club one or two maybe New York Comedy
Club to stand I don't feel like running
around like rushing around you know I'm
not my fourth I'm not my 20s anymore
where I'm just jumping I start doing
this running and do another set called
back over here I'm like I'm good and you
know what I mean I'm working on my [ __ ]
I know what I need to do I'm like
sometimes I look just like to stay in
the saiyans like I'll do three shows
that I did New Year's Eve I did four
shows at the stand to stay there all
night oh it's perfect other the only
time that sucks is when they're in
between shows and it's gets a little
packed but then they
put them downstairs and you find yeah
what do you how much stand up do you do
with all these like TV shows and books
and all that type how often you get to
weekend's oh I'm on the road two
weekends a month oh that's good yeah and
I do one weekend in New York and then I
take one weekend off so I got my son one
weekend a month the law also during a
week to seven that's amazing so he's
already getting understand that he's
been on stage like five times and he
plays like from you like the coolest kid
drums sing and now now he's all about
stand-up now because I took him out I
there was a show - Ronnie be a
bennington does a show his radio show
and the Hard Rock in New York every year
does a live show does 400 people sold
out and he did a segment where you go
comedians go up and tell an old joke so
I brought my son with me and he goes
Luke if you want to go on stage you
could tell an old joke is okay I will
and he went up there I introduced from
the place went nuts he grabs the mic and
I didn't even tell him I said it goes
are you guys ready to hear a funny joke
hit on like maze already work in a
crowded place cuz nothing is a home I
know and he tells a joke and the play
and it gets an applause break and he's
up there and we stood up on say for
another 10 minutes he felt that ever
since then he's like I got a show
tonight come on go get a show let's just
go get a show just you know on stage
right you can go down to the club oh
yeah I could come on we got a - why
don't we do win a show you know it's
gonna be funny is that when he has to do
like a book report I'm about nervous she
would get he's gonna be like all amped
up to do it he's gonna be psyched I
think when I was in school I would just
be like I would be so scared and then
she wouldn't call the teacher wouldn't
call him he would be like thank God and
then I seen my buddy go up and then when
he'd be done I'd be like [ __ ] I wish I
was him because it would be over and
yeah I can or oh boy horrible [ __ ] I
guess was that stage fright and public
speaking yeah I mean once I knew I
wanted to do calm and it took me a year
to get on stage you get the balls to get
on stage I was petrified that's what I
did I gave myself I made a new year's
resolution in 1992 I was a at some point
in this year I gave myself a whole year
to do it was funny but the second I did
it all of a sudden was a talent contest
like in January and I just signed up for
it and it was like a month out and then
there was so many guys they pushed it
and so I started like right in the
beginning of March
and yeah like horrible horrible like I
wish like I actually had I think that's
great for a kid to I think it's great
for him to meet a lot of people you know
like like we've had a lot of people come
over the first year of my daughter's
life and so like when people come over
she's not really like oh my god who's
that
it doesn't [ __ ] with their universe and
then to get them you know to talk to the
adults or speak you know publicly or
something I think that's a huge that's
something I wish you know I was so
[ __ ] shy I almost feel like someone
needed to do that to kind of nudge me
out but if they did I probably wouldn't
have been as [ __ ] up I would have
become true yeah I would have been some
guy and it's funny way up to management
at this point and he's only a first
grader ones like oh so he must be the
class clown and classical no he's not I
go that's why he could be a good comic
he's not the guy you know hey look at me
over here because those guys are never
good yeah there's a lot of hacks in
elementary you know fart jokes yeah Adam
Aiken face and those guys that try to do
comedy later are terrible that are
terrible that you know you want the
quiet guy that's just sitting back and
observing everything and and remembering
and writing it down you don't want a guy
jumping on the desk that's the guy he's
gonna be a hack he's gonna do he's a guy
you end up meeting at your show later
he's a sick dude I was funnier than you
I should have done this [ __ ] you're like
well go go do it or if he does stand if
he's the guy does the arms thing at the
end more to go behind a comic and work
the arms how great was that though the
first time you saw it was hilarious it
was the greatest thing ever cuz I so I
had an itch down my crotch and they'd
have some hot girl and see that together
do you know one of the one of the most
misunderstood comedians of all time I
believe is Gallagher because everybody
looks at him like he was this [ __ ]
guy smashing all the [ __ ] he was making
fun of advertising that's what that bit
was right sledge-o-matic what the hell
is it and it didn't work but was all
this visual stuff but so many people
took it at face value they just wanted
to go like oh my god we're gonna get
like cottage cheese all have an orange
juice all over they never got the bit
and what killed me is if you watched the
beginning of his act he had some really
really good
Tyrael clever material I'm on what time
Patrice rest his soul was talking to him
on the Opie and Anthony show and he was
saying how you know you need to pick a
path you know he was good you can either
gonna do this Carlin stuff or you're
gonna be the guy smash and [ __ ] and like
he just wasn't able to convey it in a
way and I remember listening to it I was
driving I was listening to on the radio
I was just going like yes yes exactly
he had that [ __ ] bit where he sat
down in the school desk they did this
whole bit where he starts talking about
how weird words are spelled in our
length and our English language he
started with the word I just remember
him going like something like I ended up
going to like like heard and then he
point here is this a bird no beard B ard
and you did the whole [ __ ] thing and
then in the end he got back to the word
that he started with and then he just
does this it just all in circles and
that's why I didn't go to school it's
like [ __ ] great bit yeah but some
reason he had to be sitting at a school
desk when he did it everybody starts
gonna always a prop guy I don't know no
I remember he used to do his stand-up I
remember seen in like Showtime as a kid
he was on rollerskates right didn't he
do a thing where he a giant couch he put
a trampoline in and [ __ ] and like every
so everybody would remember that right
but in the middle of all that he had
this no yeah I know he did I remember at
the end he wins but yeah he was almost
like Carlin back in a day like a good
smart material it was funny yeah but
yeah you come out in a giant [ __ ]
tricycle and then and then a lot of it
gets lost the grace and then he retires
and he sells his act to his brother
Gallagher - Gallagher - goes out he
starts making a fortune and then Gallo
gets jealous wait a minute
now I want my act back he said no you
sold it to me and then they had to go to
court
yeah now Gallagher - can't do it anymore
so get the real Gallagher's back out
there yeah he he told him to do it when
he couldn't I think I've heard so many
stories and then he told to stop doing
it I just remember when that came when
Gallagher - came to Boston it was the
funniest [ __ ] thing because like
Gallagher to to the layman's sounded
like oh he wrote a new hour you know
what I mean like Ghostbusters
Ghostbusters Part two Gallagher
Gallagher part two right so he would go
up there and it would be like
it would it wouldn't take any more than
three or four minutes like right out of
the gate is like why does his voice
sound so weird does he kind of look like
him if you sat in the back and then
people just start what with informants
like dude this isn't Gallagher who the
[ __ ] is this and then this murmur would
start and he'd the [ __ ] guy wouldn't
even address it he would stay up there
for an hour there's people going like
who the [ __ ] is this guy I only watched
the first ten minutes I had to run out
and go to his spot but right the tension
in the room but I was back then where
you could actually just do 40 remember
45 was closing just do 45 minutes yeah
somehow then it became like an hour I
could say I still do 45 a lot of times
45 on the road sometimes I'm just I'm
just gonna do 45 feels like a club and
they got a second yeah like a funny bone
or something like that they got a second
show but even sometimes I just feel like
doing 45 45 is great it's the best yeah
cuz you look down and you get you're a
35 year I [ __ ] ten more nothing I
want to get offstage romic articies
going good I'm good 45 minutes to close
that's like having a beer in the
afternoon and you got nothing to doing
for the rest of the [ __ ] day you know
I'm jealous of his clean comics who get
to like like I've heard Regan will do
like afternoon like a matinee show and
if I ever for some reason could find
enough [ __ ] animals to show up for a
matinee show for me I would stop working
at night I would do a [ __ ] two
o'clock it's like in radio remember Opie
used to always telling me about like
doing how afternoon drive is like the
greatest thing because you know you have
a life like you can if you still want to
go out that night you can no matter how
hard you hit it you could sleep because
you're not back on the air until like
noon a 1 or 2 o'clock in the afternoon
but I don't know when I get old and my
whole crowd turns into like the blue
hairs like I will have no [ __ ]
problem switching to being the met I'll
[ __ ] do it
I'll do an afternoon show no you can do
a 5 o'clock a 5 o'clock and a 7:30
easily I people want to go out early and
all the comedy clubs of switches time so
like 7 o'clock 7:30 in a Friday first
show and 7 o'clock on a Saturday you
know what I hate the most 8 7 and 10 oh
yeah so it's time and they get out of me
absolutely way too much time so you get
the goody-goodies show
up at ten and then you get the [ __ ]
meth heads at seven then you get the
meth heads at ten I always think like
what can we just do seven and nine seven
and nine just exactly I'll do for my
type 45 we get a man what time do you
need me off so you can turn this room
over another pet peeve of mine
now we're gonna [ __ ] about clubs when
the first show starts late it's like how
did it start late you knew what I can
see the second show starting late
because you know somebody spilled some
drinks and [ __ ] this is the fizzes right
out of the [ __ ] game yeah you don't
want to you want to put yourself in a
hole right off the bat if it's seven
o'clock there's no reason for it to
start at 7:15 just start at 7:00 the MCS
got to take the bullet I took the bullet
you took the bullet when you were MC in
sardis [ __ ] got to take it does
people still walking in there eating I
did sorry man yeah but you know these
kids today they're all just saying can
we wait a minute cuz you know there's
people still coming in I I always go
yeah yeah don't worry don't worry
right oh my god of [ __ ] times that's
the most amazing thing about that
Richard Pryor special the one that he
did down there at the terrorist theater
than when he had the red shirt is when
he came out there was still people
getting in their seats so anybody who's
like a nerd for comedy like that
situation is every situation that an
opener gets put in he came out as a
headliner on his own special dealt with
that situation they crushed right I
actually think you know just being a
nerd fan of his too that put him in the
zone because rather than going out and
having to jump into a bit going I am
shooting a special and and here's my
first idea he went out there and just
[ __ ] started riffing and like I think
it just after that like that it's the
greatest special of all time you don't
think he had an opener that did time no
he did what he did he had a did he have
a band I used to know this right because
I remember Eddie Murphy on delirious had
the bus boys from the movie 48 hours he
had them open who the [ __ ] did he have I
used to know this it was a Gladys Knight
or something like that it was a singer
okay and they sang and everybody [ __ ]
went out to the bathroom afterward
and they were like Richard they're still
coming back to the seats he's like not
want to go out now want to go on now
like he just was feeling it and they
just sent him out there and I think that
the chaos of it was what he kind of
thrived in I don't know this is like
some nerd [ __ ] but just this know that
I've that I've read about him like when
he was in like Vegas and everyone was
sitting down he's supposed to work clean
and like thought that whole structured
thing about that he had like a [ __ ]
meltdown but then you get him more in
that little more chaos that was like
like more of like his his comfort zone
was kind of chaos and right it seemed
for just from what I read man obviously
never met the guy I'm just saying the
worst was that I'm sure you went through
this remember when you could still smoke
in the comedy clubs the first show
saturday was a no-smoking show and they
were always uptight yeah they were
always the tight asses they weren't a
good crowd you knew if you just got
through that show the second shows gonna
be great because they were the drinkers
and smokers and they're fun people and
they'll just laugh but the first ones
are [ __ ] they want to be home early
they go out early and they don't want to
put up with any smoke and they were
always [ __ ] - yeah it felt like a job
like oh we're not they were coming up to
just get this done let's go to the
comedy show yeah we'll be home by 9:30
I remember when when when they used to
[ __ ] like buy a whole ladder on my
first like my first eight years of
stand-up that would put me to 2,000
right around 2000 I started to have the
smoke free stuff like I had actually had
like a smoker's cough a little bit I
mean I would wake up the next morning
back when I had hair and I would get in
the shower and when the water would pour
over me all the smoke that was in my
hair which I would just breathe it in
and smell like I fought a fire so what I
would I started doing was I and I
noticed I was getting a coffee what I
started doing was I'd come home after
the shows and I would immediately take a
shower and I would just [ __ ] throw my
you know I was still living at home at
the time eight years ago I was in New
York by then but like the first three
years when I was still living at home
with my parents like I would just throw
the clothes right in the [ __ ] hamper
and all of that [ __ ] and remember your
eyes would be like I mean I staged my
eyes were like burning did the funny
bone in st. Louis was always like it was
it was like a smoke machine like you
were at a concert it was like Motley
Crue's starting off you know shout at
devil yeah you couldn't see a foot in
front
the whole [ __ ] room smoked and you're
like holy [ __ ] had to do like the ratio
was on a Saturday I'm like this is
brutal I'm like yeah so do you find him
with doing like stand-up with because
when I went back to New York I couldn't
believe how many groans I was getting
like I was getting a lot of groans and
or just like people like kind of looking
each other like what if I could just
blows my mind that young people are like
they act like old people in clubs now
and I feel like they are they're like I
don't know like because they grew up on
social media like you just saying [ __ ]
like you're gonna get in trouble how
have you found it seems like you think
the New York scene is great like I'm out
of it I just went back for a couple days
and I think I was a little weirded out
by some of the the people there are you
finding it that it's who knows you've
been there like you could sort of just
because you're there every [ __ ] night
like you don't notice it change it yeah
I don't see I don't see a change in too
much I mean I don't see a change in out
here either
when I do sets at the Comedy Store to
improv I could pretty much do the same
said I'm really feel it I don't know
where you didn't but you know I know it
like it to stand or New York Comedy Club
they just come in to laugh and there's
not really no one's really gone man that
crowd sucks they're so uptight so you
know and we're not getting that at all
so you know it was I live out here now
so I'm comfortable out here so I feel
like LA crowds are better than New York
and it's just because I'm living out
here and I'm just used to it I think
that that's what it is why always hated
LA crowds when I used to come out 10 15
years ago I would you know I was like
what why is this guy so angry onstage I
just didn't get it you know what I mean
I wasn't physical I wasn't smiling all
the time and [ __ ] I'm like man he's
cries it rough and then it turned I
don't know like maybe like seven eight
years ago
yeah we're just you could do whatever
you want the comics were dirty and edgy
and they look like the Laugh Factory
because the Laugh Factory for so long
this is such a weird thing to say it was
too happy a place it was too well lit
you know and then I saw that thing in
the background looked like the Warner
Brothers that's all folks I just don't
think a big [ __ ] cartoon so I'd get
in there and you could see the whole
[ __ ] room and then I just got like
self-conscious when I would go on that
stage being like just if you said
anything [ __ ] up but now I love the
club it definitely was I tried to stay
away from that Club because I know
did well in there do you think that like
there's gonna be a backlash to this like
sort of like I don't know because I'm
not saying everything that people get
offended by is is wrong cuz that's not
accurate but the overreaction and this
just like I'm kind of thinking out every
generation rebels against the other
generation the previous I'm kind of
thinking like the next group of young
kids coming up I guess maybe it's
wishful thinking I'm hoping that they're
going to be more like the people I knew
in the 70s and 80s
I don't think so cuz this generation of
young ones now they don't drink they
don't do drugs they might smoke a little
pot they're not like promiscuous like
the last generation before that were
they were you know having sex early and
getting from no one 19 year old kids are
not going in the woods and drinkin you
don't I mean they're not getting high
they're not doing mushrooms like we did
I was I was smoking pot at 12 years old
I was drinking cigarettes when you would
hide the beers and you were all excited
like you stole everybody look like they
just steal like three beers to me dad
I'll steal three Bubba and you put
together like this the stash and then
you go and you'd bury them in the
[ __ ] woods remember when you would go
out and be so [ __ ] cold that they
froze froze and then you'd have to
[ __ ] just sit and slowly sip it
slowly sip you wouldn't even get drunk
interviews giant ice a [ __ ] beer oh
they get skunked if you left them out
there too long even this every weekend
was like you go to the woods you get as
[ __ ] up as you possibly could and then
the cops would show up every [ __ ]
weekend chase you are there and everyone
to leap in their cars wasted I mean
there has to be a happy meeting between
that and what the [ __ ] is going on I
like how I'm talking about this like I
know what kids are doing they're also
doing like [ __ ] ecstasy and meth and
[ __ ] it is pretty nuts yeah but I just
seriously like they're not they're not
out you know like drinking and stuff
like that I got a bunch of niece and
nephews and their friends and stuff like
I see it and none of them doing anything
don't touch alcohol they don't smoke
they're not even in - why would you - if
there was a flat-screen TV in your house
you know and these kids a lot of people
got like a couple of them there's like a
[ __ ] TV and like every major
in their house you can go online talk to
people playing video games you can watch
porn on your right on your phone yeah
you can watch plain you watch a plane
think I [ __ ] up it is that you can
just watch footage of a plane crashing
nobody knew what the [ __ ] that looked
like when we were grown he had to go
like he could know some war footage well
you can just watch you can literally see
anything what does it look like when a
guy jumps off the building hits the
pavement what does that look like I
don't know what that website is cuz I
was never into the death [ __ ] yeah but
you you know I remember some of those
[ __ ] comics that was came up with
when when all that Isis [ __ ] when they
was saw in people's [ __ ] heads off
they would go on and watch it and then
they would come in like oh god that was
so [ __ ] I was like why would you do
that like I actually know like I did a
bit one time about being on fire
screaming and bla bla bla bla bla and a
buddy of my comic I knew told me he goes
that's actually not the noise people
make when they get burned to death and
he started imitating the noise it was
even creepier and I'm like how the [ __ ]
do you know that and he goes ah you know
I've watched some pretty dark [ __ ] it's
like you [ __ ] somebody got burned to
death and you you sat and [ __ ]
watched it I don't know I saw one Isis
beheading video my brother sent it to me
and he's like don't worry it's not what
it is it's a joke at the end just watch
it through the end just to mess with me
and I said it was it still that was like
15 years ago ten years I still can't get
out of my mind I never watch that stuff
never I don't want to want to see
anybody get hit by a car I don't want to
see any of that what they live yeah they
let you live it's just Kyle Ike the
happy medium if you can't handle the car
is somebody getting gored by a bull
cuz it's literally like the only thing
cartoon does not exaggerate is how high
you go in the Iowa poll Hitchens drew
dude I saw I got out [ __ ] on my phone
and left my phone this guy [ __ ] this
dude's running and he's he's in general
was [ __ ] idiot he's in the ring with
a bunch of other guys a bunch of bulls
running around and he didn't have his
head on the swivel he gets [ __ ] shot
up in the air and the bull takes off and
the guy goes into like a fetal position
and then everybody comes and saves him
and now he's running like looking back
to see if the Bulls coming and as he's
looking back another Bowl comes in the
it's the guy again yeah it's just like
if he was an NFL players like he was on
special teams or some [ __ ] in his career
is gonna be over I do have to read a
little bit of advertising here but I
named you say how great it is to see I
don't ever get to see you now that I
became a big phony out here in Hollywood
logging you know when you got a kid -
man it's a whole other yeah you know
this this weekend is my daughter's first
birthday and a first birthday while I'm
baking my first cake and my wife had
invited all these people there's gonna
be all these kids there but we're gonna
have a cool like it's like adult food
right you know if you want some whiskey
or something like that whatever you know
if you're the other spouse is cool let
your drive is fine and then we got all
this cool [ __ ] for the kids you like our
gift bag is about is like this [ __ ]
bag of like gummy bears and just I don't
know kids love gummy bears right you
know ten years ago you never thought
you'd be baking a cake but my theory is
whenever you think like I don't know if
I could do this this is kind of what you
do it for the kid if there's a kid
involved you get a pass
oh yeah no wait my my wife said to me
she's going like I don't know it's gonna
be all these people because of the
recipe I had was for like a like a two
layer cake and then she don't want to
make it three and then she says like
well you know you could just go to the
grocery store and do the Duncan Hines
thing and I was like now I'm not [ __ ]
doing that right all right I'm doing
this every year like this is one of
these things that you got to have on
them on the resume for like when your
kid gets old to be like what kind of dad
what kind of dad was my dad made me a
cake every year I got at least have that
because I'm a [ __ ] lunatic and I know
I'm gonna snap well my son he's got a
little person to be around I'm an
[ __ ] so I just got to come through
with a cake right no you have to
document everything too because they
don't believe you that's the advice I
got from other parents take pictures
because they're not gonna believe that
you took him to Disneyland every year
and all and you did all the [ __ ] with
them so I whenever I take my son
anywhere an event I take a picture so I
go hey [ __ ] this is what I did
at 5:00 that's what I did at 6:00 look
what I did Dan Marino tell me that
Marino told me to have one tag good you
know he came out to my show and I didn't
get to see him yeah tell me see what hey
Dan Marino was out when I was in Fort
Lauderdale it's like [ __ ] I would've
loved if he came back he's such like a
humble guy all he's crazy
he's awesome and I got to tell him what
I've been wanting to tell forever I was
like dude if you played today in your
prime with these rules of coverage you
would throw for 6,000 yards without a
problem every season and he's and I
appreciate that I appreciate that no he
knows he still loves to show off his arm
he loves to just go let me just show you
when he did those rock and jock things
under Super Bowl does rappers you know
like q-tip or something and he's firing
at him there did you say guys he must
have watched the Dan Marino football
life phenomenal was it arm goes up ball
comes out it still looked like when they
were just showing him throwing the ball
it looked like they sped up the film
it's like us it's like a [ __ ] Viper
you can't even see it it just [ __ ]
goes up in the background and it's a
tight spiral um that's funny listen
[ __ ] I took you here it took you
here you're gonna say yeah so just take
document and take pictures the whole
time we didn't do anything dad I'm
already worried that when they go
through that period we're inevitably
they hate you cuz they gets the kid gets
to a point where they know enough [ __ ]
that they think they're ready to live on
their own that comes around like what 11
12 13 and then you just got then you
just gotta wait - they're like 26 I
think and then they kind of like gotta
wait a minute you know it's a rough it
seems like it's like a rough 15 years
let me read this book yeah yeah stop
doing this dr. Phil [ __ ] all right ah me
undies everybody owe me undies me undies
[ __ ] I took you here Bo - dude do
me undies me undies I opened your
[ __ ] first beer all right me undies
you want to look good in your underwear
and be comfortable right but that
perfect balance is hard to find down
sacrifice style or comfort why would you
do that talk about why me undies is the
best underwear you will ever own well
it's free they send it to me you know so
I'll wear it feel good at Phil's on my
balls and then I'll tell you guys how
great it is it's it is I got to tell you
it is pretty amazing and it's got a
superhero vibe to its always feel a
little stronger when I wear it does that
contractually fill my obligation there
me undies will be the most comfortable
pair of underwear you will ever own made
from sustainably sourced natural soft
fabric that is three times softer than
cotton all
amid feel-good undies for what you want
to feel so one for when you want to feel
naked what ultimate feel-good undies for
when you want to feel naked not be naked
alright sentence always trips me up 100
cent satisfaction guarantee they
guaranteed you will love your undies or
your money back right now
me undies has an exclusive offer from my
listeners get 20% off your first pair
and the and free shipping and me unease
is so sure you will love this their
underwear they even offer a 100%
satisfaction guarantee this is the point
in the coffee when I want to start
[ __ ] crying because I'm so bad at
reading out loud and I still have like
another three paragraphs alright you
order a pair and if you don't love your
first pair get a full refund there's
this is a no-brainer 20% off free
shipping and 100% satisfaction guarantee
what are you waiting for to get you 20%
off free shipping and their 100 cent
satisfaction guarantee you can get the
best and softest underwear you will ever
own go to me undies calm cyber that's my
undies calm cyber this is a limited time
offer so what are you waiting for
start wearing the best underwear of your
life it changed my life evidently
according to the copy yeah if I wasn't
wearing these I wouldn't had jim
Florentine on here promoting his book
everybody's awful except for you and
available now that's like the joke
within a joke the ad within an ad start
wearing the best underwear of your life
it changed my life it's time to let me
undies change yours go to me undies calm
slash / right now alright let's wrap
this up I want to get jim Florentine and
Florentine Florentine Florentines NFL
picks for this weekend Patriots Jags you
already picked the Pats now let's talk
about the Eagles and the Vikings two
teams that have never won a Super Bowl
neither the jaguars three out of four
teams have not won a Super Bowl that's a
tough one this is gonna be you know cuz
the two backup quarterbacks in there
Minnesota's got a good you don't know
what Nick Foles is gonna show up right
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go Philly
you're gonna go Philly I'm gonna go
Philly at home Philly at home [ __ ] yeah
and all that excitement in Minnesota
yeah I think so and yeah city of brother
because they should have lost that New
Orleans game they should have you know
lose it and then New Orleans [ __ ] the
whole thing up so yeah it was imagine if
you were a die-hard Saints fan and now
what that would be like that would
literally be like if you [ __ ] if you
did a [ __ ] stand-up special you had
the greatest special of all [ __ ] time
and then right at the end of your
special you want to put the mic in the
mic stain and somehow you did like a
[ __ ] faceplant
I'm trying to think like what you could
do like you did it or maybe there was no
audio oh yes it was wave no but you'd
have to go and somehow you you [ __ ] up
are you okay yeah no in the end you just
like [ __ ] kids and you take your dick
out and yeah so I think yeah the Eagles
maybe a field goal they'll win it win a
by feet and it'll be Philly and Patriots
and Patriots you know okay 31 20
something like that I'm like that
yeah I'm hoping the Patriots win and
Brady some I didn't you just look at the
quarterbacks that's where you get it I'm
good how has a better defense Eagles or
Vikings the Vikings I kind of what the
Vikings are on the road they got in a
better defense and then you know they
got a backup but he's their guy at this
point yeah
Case Keenum that's what's making me feel
old now is the names of quarterback case
Carson it's just like our generations
gone yeah there's no gems there's no
bills no there's no not anymore there's
no Steve remember Steve there's no Steve
de Burgh anymore yes Steve Marino
you know Steve Young the only guy left
is like Jay your guy Jake Oh Jay Cutler
yeah well yeah Jake's not as my field
goal kickers Cody
I met there was never a Kohli on the
Dolphins till last year oh they love to
see names at home everybody born in the
90s see that like a sea Dame it started
with Clemens oh no he named everything
with a k' oh yeah yeah at a Cody but
like it was that all right so you pick
it up I'm gonna say I'm hoping the
Patriots win and then I have no idea
such a [ __ ] hard one I would actually
say the Vikings go in and break the
Eagles heart but the football God smiled
on him last week
am I going to go against the Vikings
again this
week I can't do that because then if
they win I'll have to go against him
again if the Patriots win and then I'll
be jinx in my own team so do I pick
enough [ __ ] dad and I don't think
there's gonna be a big home-field
advantage of the Vikings getting to
Super Bowl a lot of those of corporate
tickets and it doesn't did the Patriots
can play anywhere so it doesn't matter
Mike I think that's a tough one that's
the game
Vikings Eagles is a game that's gonna be
a good one I'm gonna say Vikings
I'll pick no you took the Eagles I'll
take the Vikings [ __ ] I'll take the
Vikings yeah I just think the old Nick
Foles is gonna show up old Nick Foles
shows up but both of those [ __ ] teams
both those franchises the football gods
love to [ __ ] yank the rug out from
underneath I know I think there's a
chance of stadium might collapse on the
boat either way it's gonna be great Jim
so great to see it so awesome to have
you on the podcast and once again
everybody is awful except you is
available now from the yeah pretty or
pretty or 20th and February 20th you can
get it on Amazon Barnes and Noble and to
quote jim Florentine all of that [ __ ]
you'll be able to get it really happy
for you buddy continued success and I
hope to run into you in New York
alright thanks man all right